at the adidas innovations lab in
Portland Oregon
the company is getting ready for a
marathon
what kind of investment was the creation
of this film for adidas we spend
millions of dollars on R&D and this is
one of our biggest programs so it's a
multi-million dollar investment adidas
has packed this lab with high-tech
equipment and is using science to grab a
slice of the lucrative running shoes if
you took basketball and you doubled it
and you put any shoe with a cleat on the
bottom from soccer baseball football
anything track put them together it's
smaller than then running women's
running is bigger than basketball it's
just giant only a fraction of the 30
million active runners in the United
States where adidas running shoes the
company wants to change that with the
new spring Blade and boosts shoes this
is the market where we're most off and
this is what we need in this market
adidas spent years creating boosts
innovative cushioning that they say
returns energy to the runner runner's
world magazine called it the best debut
of 2013 was it a big gamble for adidas I
think all of our innovations are a
gamble of some sort and we do try to
hedge our bets as much as possible so
adidas is not just now a sports apparel
company it's also a technology company
as well yes absolutely after years of
testing the new shoe hit stores late
last year but it's too early to tell if
it D disses investment and innovation
will make runners invest in Adidas I
think this will help our top-line our
bottom line every line